rick what's the excitement level locally
i know it's a weird time with the
pandemic and everything but tampa bay
buccaneers first team to host the super
bowl and play in it one to ten what's
the level of excitement down there right
now
well i mean given the circumstances it's
probably about a nine nine and a half i
mean it's unfortunate you know that this
is now as you know mike the city of
champions i mean we've had you know uh
the the lightning win the stanley cup
the race go to six games in the world
series and now um the bucks and there
will be fans there uh you know many of
them from tampa bay but look they're
pretty jacked up about the bucks it's
been 13 years since this team was in the
playoffs you get tom brady and you go to
the super bowl the first one in their
home stadium you know of any super bowl
team i mean that's that's pretty heavy
stuff so uh they're living a fairy tale
right now they just wish that more
people could participate in
rick you've been in tampa of course
forever and when i got there in 1994 i
think we were in the midst of the
longest double-digit losing streak in
the nfl and in history and you mentioned
how this city has really turned it
around but in your lifetime when you're
back covering all those bad teams did
you expect to see one super bowl plus
two super bowls with the greatest
quarterback of all time now
quarterbacking this one because the
first one was completely different from
this they had a
mediocre quarterback and a really good
defense
yeah you know shireen i i try uh not to
have memories of all those bad seasons
but you know it's the worst winning
percentage in north american sports
right i had the pleasure of covering all
those losses many of them with you
um and and guys like warren sapp and
derek brooks they turned it around you
know with tony duchy then john gruden
came in got him over the hump and they
won a couple nfc south titles after that
but never really got close when you go
13 years without even going to the post
season i mean that's so that's a long
time right and all those coaches they
had something like five and nine years i
mean it's just been a parade through
here um so you know first bruce arians
and the winston thing didn't work out
but yeah who expected uh when you
started you know this time a year ago
that tom brady would leave new england
come to tampa bay and and with all that
was against him would lead this team to
a super bowl i mean it's really just
storybook and you know we'll have to see
what the ending is in a couple weeks in
a week or so
and rick there were flashes early in the
year suggesting that the buccaneers were
capable of this but there was a lot of
bad as well whether it was the week nine
game the blowout loss to the new orleans
saints and then there they were week 12
seven and five the loss to the kansas
city chiefs they go into the bye week
they come out of it and they're seven
and oh from seven and five to seven and
0. what happened during that two-week
period that allowed them to get to this
point where they're unbeatable
well i think a couple things uh you know
mike i think first of all
they actually played well in the second
half against kansas city they got down
in that game 17 to nothing but
offensively they found some things and
then when they went to the bye week i
think that you know they needed time on
task really uh you know they got with
byron leftwich they gave tom brady some
things that he needed more of right more
of a commitment to the running game more
play action
more pre-snap motion some of those
things that that he was used to
and yet he still ran their offense and
they got to get
a little fat on some tomato cans right
they played the atlanta falcons twice
they played the detroit lions they beat
up on some teams that weren't going very
well minnesota was okay when they got
here but they got the confidence going
and it's really just grown week to week
because receivers the defense has come
on especially the last part of the year
and you know voila i mean i credit a lot
of it to tom brady byron leftwich
getting things together you see the
protection he has now you see the
commitment to running the football
it's been all you know working together
and that's what good teams do
rick you mentioned that week 12 game in
the first quarter tyree kill went over
200 yards um and he ended up with 269
and three touchdowns did they learn how
to stop him in the last three quarters
of that game because that's obviously
going to be a big storyline going into
this game how do they stop tyree kill
well they learned that carl davis can't
cover man-to-man i mean you know i like
the
little debate whether scottie miller or
tyreek kill is faster they should just
ask carlton davis he's been beaten by
both of them i mean he would know but
man you know i mean top goals uh i don't
you know i i often wonder like what were
the plans you rejected that night like
no no that defense won't work like that
that was your solution so when the guy's
doing backflips in your end zone and
it's still the first quarter and he's
got two honey on you you might want to
try something else so what i would
suspect
is that you'll see some safety help you
might see some some you know mad
coverage or with safeties over the top i
mean these guys have been really
aggressive on defense um you know trying
to
to sit on some some corner routes but
we'll see i mean they got to stop him
more worried quite frankly about travis
kelsey in that game which is why tyree
kill really got off so you've got
several weapons over there and of course
the quarterback he just keeps running
backwards 25 yards and throwing dimes so
it's it's really hard to get pressure on
him even if you get past that offensive
line
that's a problem with hill and kelsey
you know you'd ideally like to take one
away the problem is sometimes you take
neither away like we saw last week with
the buffalo bills tom brady has been
great in his first season with the team
and i can remember back earlier in the
year when bruce arians was periodically
criticizing brady i had heard you know
folks down there higher up in the
organization a little nervous about it
because above all else they wanted brady
to want to come back next year and i
think it's a given he'll be back next
year how long do you think that
relationship is going to last beyond
2021 because my guess is bucks fans want
him to hang around as long as possible
and he's talked about playing until he's
45. i could see him playing longer than
that i could see him playing for the
buccaneers longer than that
yeah well i i mean i think you know
bruce arians has said that he expects
andy reed coach until he's 80 as long as
patrick mahomes is around and that's
probably the direction that ba is headed
you know all that stuff in the beginning
of the season it was shocking especially
the new england fans to hear tom brady
the goat get called out but the reality
is that's who bruce busarians has always
been and i i think we'd be remiss to
think that tom brady didn't talk to
peyton manning didn't talk to ben
roethlisberger or carson palmer he knew
exactly what he was getting into but
with all that criticism and usually it's
constructive i mean he's not being
personal about it he'll tell you your
football sucks you know that's what he
tells his players i'm not not trying to
be personal but then he throws his arm
around him he's let brady beat tom brady
he can breathe a little bit you've seen
the social media game step up you've
seen him um you know enjoying his time
uh you know in this sunshine literally
so i just think that you know it was a a
refresher uh you know a refreshing move
away from belichick for sure um and he
just had to get used to to bruce's
abrupt nature especially in the media
but the coaches i talked to said he
never complained he never said anything
about it um he just came in every day
and worked hard and there never seemed
to be a rift between anybody
rick this is a team that was better on
the road this year than they were at
home they won all three postseason games
on the road and now we're making a big
deal of hey they're the first team
in nfl history to host a super bowl in
their own stadium
yet there's only going to be 22 000 fans
in there somewhere around there it's a
corporate event as we all know is there
any type of home field advantage they're
going to have in this game
um i don't even know if they're going to
blast the cannons when they get in the
20s sharing so i would say probably not
much except that when you go on the road
three straight weeks in the postseason
and and yeah i can attest it it looked
nice but it was cold in green bay okay
um they're happy to be back here and and
sleeping in their own beds as they say
kansas city is sleeping in theirs by the
way until like saturday night so i don't
think there's much of a home field
advantage there hasn't been one
throughout
the league this year that's why they
were able to do this i think this was
the year if you were to go on the road
and win um despite all the signs being
smashed at lambeau field uh you know it
sounded like a playoff atmosphere but it
wasn't like it would have been so um
look
they're in their own city i mean they
got a visual reminder shireen and this
was the thing going into green bay i
mean right across the stadium as you
know or across the practice field is
this stadium that's that's decked out
for super bowl 55 so i mean that was
sort of the carrot and um yeah they can
look over there and dream and in a
little over a week they'll have a chance
to actually be in that game and um you
know i think that's the home field
advantage is that they've known it was
going to be here and the idea that
another nsbc team like the packers or
saints would come in here
and uh take over that stadium i think
was was not too appetizing to him
rick i'm glad you mentioned the cannons
because i assume we have a potential
eyewitness here chris sims claims that
when he scored a rushing touchdown
against washington in the playoffs in
2005 his celebration included throwing
the ball in the direction of the pirate
ship and into one of the cannon halls he
they claim al mcguire or paul mcguire
not alan mcguire a different sport paul
mcguire on the broadcast said it
happened chris swears it happened i have
no visual evidence of it did you happen
to see that one way or the other
no i didn't see it one way or the other
but i i would like to have seen it and i
think we would have been told about it
before he told you guys um that would
have been maybe one of chris
and uh he made a lot of good throws but
no i don't remember that one what i
remember about chris sims is a throw to
edel shepard i think in the back of the
end zone that they said he didn't
maintain possession or they would have
maybe won a playoff game there but uh
not cannons
rick do you see this team possibly being
better last next year considering that
they in the off season they had no real
offseason the saints look like they're
going to be sort of rebuilding mode
could this be an even better team next
year
well i mean presumably right i mean you
got to see who you can keep i mean
they've got a lot of free agents you
know starting with chris godwin they've
got to decide what to do with shaq
barrett who is their franchise player
and domicon soon doesn't want to play
another year um you know and then you
know i i do think that tom brady with
the year in this offense knowing his
receivers um you know having it some
kind of an offseason whether it's otas
or even a training camp or a preseason
game or two remember they started the
year at new orleans which was really
unfair for them because the saints had
all that time together with sean payton
and drew brees and those guys so i know
what brady's mentality will be winner
lose is that hey you think this was good
wait till next season but you guys all
know that even tom brady didn't go every
season to the super bowl it just seems
like it was about every other season but
um with the nfc south as you mentioned
if drew brees doesn't come back james
winston going to be the quarterback
there carolina's still a long way from
being a contender atlanta looks like
they're starting over with salary cap
problems i mean bucks will be favored
and the one thing they haven't done in a
long long time is win the division and
that certainly helps you when you get
into the postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports